installing sir companion
there's American researcher who becomes
the famous and got summers attention to
human the little relations event ending
its way Dian Fossey was a hero of this
year will courage to go into a forest
and a little Africa she became a pioneer
Diane undoubtedly saved a species
neither destiny nor fate took me to
Africa nor was it romance I had a deep
wish to see and live among mountain
gorillas this woman found regression
totally Cheyenne conveyed her passion
for these animals she was someone who
liked being alone a the gelati type
attitude towards protecting gorillas he
had made enemies with alarm assumptions
by the way was poachers houses nuisance
man it was there at her camp this was a
bizarre I think there's some kind on the
segment numerous continue what is the
murderers say I do remember [ __ ] they
did kind of believe her black metal is
were to kiddin me what was the motive
for telling her we did that
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]